[Musik]
hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live und heute schauen wir wieder nach
Afghanistan und nach wie vor etliche
Menschen festsitzen und gerne raus
möchten aus Angst vor den talibanen und
insbesondere all jene die mit dem Westen
zuvor zusammengearbeitet haben die
fürchten um ihr Leben also so auch Leute
die mit Deutschland zusammengearbeitet
haben zum Beispiel als Dolmetscherinnen
und Dolmetscher und so jemand haben wir
heute auch in der Sendung einen
afghanischen Übersetzer mit dem ihr mit
dem wir sprechen wollen gleichzeitig
findet in wenigen Minuten die
Pressekonferenz mit Heiko Maas statt dem
Bundesaußenminister und da wollen wir
jetzt auch mal live hinschauen ob wir
schon was sehen ob sich etwas tut das
Pult ist noch leer aber in jedem Moment
soll die dann beginnen und er hatte sich
eben zuvor mit dem Krisenstab der
Bundesregierung getroffen weil es gibt
viele Fragen und auch viel Kritik jetzt
an der ersten Evakuierungsaktion die
gestartet ist dem einen Flugzeug was
also mit nur sieben Menschen Afghanistan
verlassen hat und wir wollen heute
sprechen neben unserem Übersetzer aus
Afghanistan der uns zugeschaltet war
auch mit unserem
hauptstadtkorrespondenten Andreas
Kühnast der für uns natürlich auch live
die Pressekonferenz beobachtet Andreas
da sehe ich sie schon und dann
vielleicht auch gleich mal die Frage
vorneweg was erwarten sie denn von der
heutigen Pressekonferenz mit dem
Außenminister
ja die Kritik an diesem ersten
evakuierungsflug du hast es ja gesagt
die war verheerend also dass da bei
diesem ersten Flug nur sieben Leute
gerettet wurden und das Auswärtige Amt
versucht schon seit vergangener Nacht im
Prinzip so detailliert wie möglich zu
schildern wie dramatisch die Ereignisse
waren in der vergangenen Nacht um
möglichst viel Verständnis zu wecken um
wenigstens eine Nachvollziehbarkeit zu
erwecken und das Auswärtige Amt wird
jetzt natürlich die Gelegenheit nutzen
um nach diesem Jahr Misserfolg nach
diesem verheerenden Bild das Deutschland
da abgegeben hat zu berichten dass es in
letzter Zeit in den letzten Stunden
besser läuft also wir haben jetzt gehört
dass heute tagsüber zwei
Transportflugzeuge
100 m nach Kabul geflogen sind dort
jeweils so um die 120/130 Menschen
gerettet haben dass die Luftbrücke
zwischen Kabul und der usbekischen
Hauptstadt Taschkent damit jetzt doch
noch so langsam Gestalt annimmt und dass
das schlechte Bild das Deutschland
abgegeben hat sich jetzt doch so langsam
ein bisschen aufhält und ich bin mir
ganz sicher dass es das sein wird was
uns der Außenminister gleich verkündet
vielen Dank Andreas ich habe den Blick
auf der Uhr weil um 15:30 Uhr soll es
losgehen wir warten noch einen Moment du
bleibst sowieso für uns die ganze Zeit
vor Ort und wir sprechen natürlich auch
im Anschluss über das was da gesagt wird
und vielleicht auch mögliche neue Fragen
die sich dann ergeben haben und im
Nachgang das wollen wir vielleicht auch
noch kurz ankündigen werden wir außerdem
auch noch mit Erik Marquardt von den
Grünen und Mitglied des Europaparlaments
sprechen der sich in den letzten Tagen
und auch heute sehr kritisch auch
geäußert hat gegenüber der
Bundesregierung und dem Einsatz und ich
würde vorschlagen wir schauen noch
einmal rüber ob sie denn pünktlich
anfangen und wenn nicht hören wir uns
gleich wieder Andreas dann schauen wir
gleich noch mal und jetzt vielleicht
noch einmal kurz rüber und haben nach
wie vor ein leeres Pult naja gut dann
haben wir noch ein bisschen Zeit zu
sprechen das ist ja gut und zwar Andreas
du hattest ja eben schon einmal
angesprochen was natürlich die
drängendste Frage ist die da jetzt
beantwortet werden muss aber vielleicht
welche anderen Fragen ergeben sich noch
du hast eine Luftbrücke angesprochen ist
vielleicht auch schon klar wie sich die
die Bundesregierung das jetzt
vorgestellt hat wie das ablaufen soll in
den nächsten Tagen also die Luftbrücke
soll so lange wie möglich stehen und sie
soll so viele Menschen wie möglich
retten das ist so der Tagesbefehl den
das
Bundesverteidigungsministerium
ausgegeben hat es ist jetzt erstmal
gelungen auf den Flughafen in Kabul
Fallschirmjäger der Bundeswehr zu
stationieren es ist gelungen dort
Spezialkräfte zur stationieren Sanitäter
also es entsteht langsam eine
Infrastruktur auf dem Flughafen Kabul wo
man die Deutschen und die vor allen
Dingen natürlich die afghanischen
ortskräfte die afghanischen Helfer der
Deutschen in Empfang nehmen kann wo man
sie dann ins Flugzeug setzen kann und
nach taschkette Usbekistan fliegen kann
das war ja bisher nicht so bisher waren
die Deutschen angewiesen auf die
Spezialkräfte anderer Staaten die den
Flughafen bewacht haben vor allen Dingen
die US-Amerikaner vor allen Dingen die
Türken und es gab ja zwischendurch auch
Momente in denen dieser Flughafen völlig
außer Kontrolle geraten ist wir haben ja
alle diese furchtbaren Bilder gesehen wo
sich Menschen an die Gangways geklammert
haben wo sie an den Flugzeugen sich
festgehalten haben es sind ja auch
Menschen dabei ums Leben gekommen also
das ist kein kleiner Schritt der da
bisher gelungen ist und der Plan der
Bundesregierung ist jetzt jeden Tag so
viele Menschen wie möglich auszuholen
man muss sagen dass die deutschen
Staatsangehörigen ja schon fast alle die
wollten Afghanistan verlassen haben
jetzt geht es um die afghanischen
ortskräfte und das ist ein Riesenproblem
weil viele von diesen ortskräften hier
sehr überhaupt nicht schaffen zum
Flughafen zu kommen weil die sich
versteckt haben irgendwo in Afghanistan
in irgendwelchen Häusern weil sie von
denen sie aus dann übrigens
verzweifelste hilfsnachrichten schicken
die uns dann auch erreichen und uns auch
alle ziemlich betroffen machen
also die Bundeswehr muss jetzt auch noch
Wege finden wie sie diese Menschen
erreicht wir haben gehört dass die
Botschaft nicht möchte dass die Leute
direkt zum Flughafen kommen die Lage
dort sei zu chaotisch sondern dass man
jetzt plant einen anderen Anlaufpunkt zu
nennen zum Beispiel das ehemalige
isar-hauptquartier wo die Menschen
hinkommen sollen die dann mit
Hubschraubern jetzt kommt erstmal der
Außenminister unterbrechen genau an
dieser Stelle du hast es auch gesehen
wir schalten jetzt nach Berlin und hören
dem Außenminister zu
ja guten Tag meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren
unsere
Evakuierungsaktion mit Unterstützung der
Bundeswehr ist jetzt voll angelaufen
in der heutigen Sitzung des Krisenstabes
die im 14 Uhr stattgefunden haben wir
auch weitere operative Schritte
beschlossen ein zweiter evakuierungsflug
ist vor etwa einer Stunde in Kabul
gestartet und hat 125 deutsche
Staatsbürger Afghanen und
staatsangehörige anderer Länder in
Sicherheit gebracht
100 weitere deutsche befinden sich
bereits im militärisch gesicherten
Bereich des Flughafens die Luftbrücke
führt zunächst nach Taschkent in
Usbekistan und im nächsten Schritt mit
Sonderflügen der Lufthansa nach
Deutschland
die Lage am Flughafen hat sich Gott sei
Dank stabilisiert
die Bundeswehr sichert jetzt den Zugang
für uns dort und wir arbeiten mit
Hochdruck daran dass heute im Laufe des
Tages weitere Personen
auskabul in Sicherheit gebracht werden
können
unsere Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter
die Soldatinnen und Soldaten die
Sicherheitskräfte vor Ort leisten unter
schwierigsten Bedingungen die sich
oftmals stündlich ändern
großartige Arbeit mit großem
Pragmatismus und mit großem Einsatz
dafür planen wir heute noch zwei weitere
evakuierungsflüge nach Kabul diese
werden von Taschkent aus aufbrechen wir
werden weiter alles daran setzen alle
unsere Staatsangehörigen in Sicherheit
zu bringen und auch die ortskräfte die
über viele Jahre mit uns
zusammengearbeitet haben so weit dass
die Lage weiter zulässt
der Schutz und die Sicherheit von
EU-Bürgern und ehemaligen ortskräften
wird auch ein wichtiger Teil der
heutigen Sitzung des
eu-außenministertreffens sein wir haben
bereits Angehörige anderer EU-Staaten
mit ausgeflogen und werden uns auch
weiter gegenseitig unterstützen wir
werden uns außerdem für eine
geschlossene Reaktion aller
EU-Mitgliedstaaten auf die Geschehnisse
in Afghanistan einsetzen und
gleichzeitig werden wir im eu-kreis über
unseren künftigen Umgang auch mit den
Taliban beraten müssen wir werden die
Entwicklung jetzt erst einmal sehr genau
beobachten und diejenigen die jetzt in
Afghanistan die Macht ausüben an ihren
Taten messen
als Europäische Union müssen wir aber
vor allem auch die Blick auf den Blick
auf die Stabilität in der Region richten
die Nachbarländer werden ganz sicherlich
mit weiteren Fluchtbewegungen
konfrontiert werden und wir haben jetzt
schon den Vereinten Nation signalisiert
dass wir bereit sind bei der humanitären
Versorgung dieser Menschen in den
Nachbarländern zu helfen wir brauchen
dafür aber auch letztlich ein
gemeinsames europäisches vorgehen und
darum wird es im eu-außenrat auch gleich
gehen
der Minister Johann von der dpa können
Sie ein bisschen was genaueres sagen zu
den Personengruppen zu den Menschen die
jetzt gerade an Bord des Flugzeug sind
und die heute noch ausgeflogen werden
sollen sind das auch Frauen darunter
Frauenrechtlerinnen und die anderen
Nationen
zum Beispiel
Spannung
jetzt ist gerade das Signal unterbrochen
worden wir versuchen hier jetzt
schnellstmöglich wieder zurückzuschalten
zur Pressekonferenz mit dem oder wird
das weitergezahlt dann geht weiter wir
werden über die Zusammensetzung der Pro
Personengruppen im weiteren Verlauf des
Tages berichten es handelt sich um
deutsche Staatsbürger es handelt sich
auch um Afghane und es handelt sich um
staatsangehörige anderer Länder
wir werden ganz sicherlich auch bei den
Flügen die heute und hoffentlich auch in
den kommenden Tagen stattfinden eine
ähnliche Zusammensetzung auf den Flügen
haben aber natürlich sind wir davon
abhängig wer wann in dem Bereich des
Flughafens kommt auf jeden Fall haben
wir mit den
bundeswehrsoldatinnen und Soldaten die
vor Ort sind gemeinsam mit den
Vereinigten Staaten eine Schleuse
organisiert ein Tor am Flughafen an das
die betreffenden Personen kommen können
dort in Empfang genommen werden und von
dort aus in den gesicherten Bereich des
Flughafens gebracht werden
was die Entwicklungshilfe angeht aber
genauso unsere Stabilisierungsmaßnahmen
haben wir diese Mittel jetzt erst einmal
eingefroren weil wir uns natürlich
ansehen wollen wie die weitere
Entwicklung in Afghanistan sein wird das
tun nicht nur wir das tun auch andere
Staaten es gilt zu überprüfen wo man
humanitär helfen kann
das gilt aber nicht nur für Afghanistan
das wird in der kommenden Zeit vor allen
Dingen für die Menschen gelten die aus
Afghanistan fliehen in die
Nachbarstaaten waren das alle Fragen
Herr Minister sind die Warnungen der
deutschen Botschaft in Kabul echtzeitig
wahrgenommen worden oder sind die
folgenlos geblieben und ziehen Sie hier
auch eigene Konsequenzen aus ihrem
Verhalten insbesondere den letzten
Wochen und Tagen insbesondere und eine
zweite Frage sie haben eben schon das
europäische Vorgehen bei den
Flüchtlingsströmen die da möglicherweise
kommen betont welche Rolle muss hier
insbesondere Deutschland einnehmen ich
möchte hier noch mal kurz an die Lasche
zitieren der sagte 2015 dürfte sich
nicht wiederholen ich glaube dass die
Europäische Union insgesamt ein
Interesse daran haben muss dass wir in
diesen Fragen eine gemeinsame Haltung
haben wir sehen wie sich die Dinge
entwickeln wir haben das im übrigen auch
in Litauen gesehen wo aufgrund des
Verhaltens von Lukaschenko in Belarus
man sich auch plötzlich mit
Migrationsfragen konfrontiert gesehen
hat und auch auf die Solidarität anderer
europäischer Staaten gesetzt hat das
wird mit Blick auf Afghanistan genauso
sein ich glaube das ist jetzt zunächst
einmal darum gehen wird die Menschen die
Afghanistan verlassen und man muss davon
ausgehen dass das eine nicht
unerhebliche Zahl sein wird die werden
zuerst in die Nachbarländer von
Afghanistan gehen dass wir diese Länder
dabei unterstützen das müssen wir als
Europäische Union tun aber wir werden
auch bilateral mit diesen Ländern
Kontakt aufnehmen was die Frage nach der
deutschen Botschaft angeht diese Meldung
habe ich gesehen so wie es gemeldet ist
oder so wie es von ihnen dargestellt
worden ist ist nicht richtig der
Krisenstab der Bundesregierung hat am
Freitag beschlossen dass unsere
Botschaft sich auf eine Evakuierung
vorbereitet im übrigen im Gleichklang
mit dem Botschaften anderer Länder auch
die unmittelbar neben unserer Botschaft
platziert gewesen sind und wir haben an
diesem Freitag bereits die Planungen der
Bundeswehr dafür aktiviert das heißt
auch in diesem Zusammenhang haben wir
genauso wie andere Staaten die Zeitpläne
umgesetzt die wir auch gemeinsam mit
anderen Staaten so besprochen haben was
ich auch aus der räumlichen Situation
vor Ort in Kabul so ergibt im übrigen
auch die Botschaft war aber auch am
Freitag noch der Auffassung dass die
Sicherheit kurzfristig gewährleistet
werden kann auch hat das ergibt sich aus
den Einlassungen der Botschaft und aus
den entsprechenden Diskussionen die es
in Krisenstab der Bundesregierung
gegeben hat am Samstag hat sich dann
erstmals abgezeichnet dass die
Sicherheit auch innerhalb der Grünen
Zone nicht mehr gewährleistet würde und
daher haben wir auch wiederum wie andere
Partnerstaaten vor Ort am Samstag
gemeinsam mit der Botschaft entschieden
die Evakuierung vorzunehmen so wie auch
andere Partner starten die dann auch am
Sonntag eingesetzt worden ist und ich
bin sehr froh dass unsere entsandten in
Sicherheit sind und ich bin genauso froh
dass es ein Kernteam gibt das weiterhin
in Kabul ist am Flughafen und sich jetzt
darum kümmert zusammen mit den Soldaten
und Soldaten der Bundeswehr dass die
deutschen Staatsbürger aber auch die
ortskräfte aus Kabul ausgeflogen werden
können dies ist relativ eindeutig
nachzuvollziehen dass wir uns genauso
verhalten haben wie andere Staaten mit
ihren Botschaften und deshalb würde ich
diese Entscheidung jederzeit auch noch
mal genauso treffen
würde mich dann interessieren war es
tatsächlich dann so dass die
Botschaftsmitarbeiter am Ende nur noch
über das amerikanische Botschaftsgelände
zum Flughafen geflogen werden konnten
mit den Helikoptern der Amerikaner
des Weiteren es wurde wochenlang
überlisten gestritten wen kann man aus
der Landes bringen jetzt sagt die
Verteidigungsministerin wir nehmen jeden
mit der in den Flieger passt wie passt
das zusammen und wenn ich ganz dreist
nur eine dritte versuchen darf gibt es
überhaupt noch eine Chance für die
Menschen die gerade nicht am Flughafen
bzw in der Nähe in Kabul sind dass man
noch zu denen kommt dass man diese auch
noch ja aus der Landes bringen kann
gerade was was auch die an den
ehemaligen deutschen Standorten angeht
also unsere Botschaftsmitarbeiter sind
wie auch andere Botschaftsmitarbeiter
von anderen Ländern also man kann es
vergleichen die gesamten Abläufe sind
bei anderen Botschaften anderer Länder
auch nicht anders gewesen mit
Hubschraubern der Amerikaner an den
Flughafen verbracht worden was die Frage
nach den Menschen angeht die sich noch
nicht unmittelbaren Umfeld des
Flughafens befinden es ist so dass in
den letzten Tagen diejenigen die sich
auf den Weg zum Flughafen gemacht haben
an den Kontrollstellen die die Teile
waren eingerichtet haben
durchgelassen haben wenn es sich um
ausländische Staatsbürger gehandelt hat
das ist auch heute so der Fall gewesen
und deshalb haben wir die deutschen
Staatsbürger auch aufgefordert sich
jetzt an den Flughafen zu begeben weil
die entsprechenden Flugzeuge der
Bundeswehr heute dort gelandet sind bzw
noch landen und wird deshalb auch weil
sich die Lage am Flughafen stabilisiert
hat weiter in der Lage sind die Menschen
die dann an den Flughafen kommen und
wenn sie ausländische Staatsbürger sind
werden sie auch durchgelassen und am
Flughafen ist die Lage so organisiert
worden dass diese Menschen auch in den
Flughafen kommen in den Bereich des
militärischen Flughafens von dem aus sie
dann ausgeflogen werden können
die zweite Frage war
es befinden sich auch jetzt bereits
ortskräfte am Flughafen deshalb sind ja
auch afghanische Staatsbürger bereits
mit auf unseren Fliegern gewesen aber
auch auf den Fliegern insbesondere der
Vereinigten Staaten wir sind dabei
zusammen insbesondere mit den
Vereinigten Staaten aber auch anderen
Partner starten zu organisieren dass die
ortskräfte auch zum Flughafen kommen
können für die ist die Lage deutlich
gefährlicher weil es die Zusage an den
entsprechenden Kontrollpunkten der
Taliban durchgelassen zu werden nicht
gibt es gelingt aber trotzdem einigen an
den Flughafen zu kommen wir wollen aber
dafür sorgen dass auch der Weg von
ortskräften aus der Stadt zum Flughafen
ein möglichst sicherer wird und daran
arbeiten wir zusammen mit anderen
Partnern die mit uns zusammen auch diese
Evakuierungsaktion organisieren
okay
das war die Pressekonferenz mit dem
Bundesaußenminister Heiko Maas und wir
wollen dazu jetzt sprechen unter anderem
mit dem hauptstadtkorrespondenten
Andreas Kühnast und natürlich sind auch
ihre eure Fragen jederzeit willkommen im
Stream oder im Chat oder auch per Mail
so wie viele von euch das vielleicht
schon kennen also jederzeit nachfragen
was ihr gerne wissen möchtet und nun
wollen wir sprechen mit unserem
hauptstadtkorrespondenten Andreas Künast
um das Ganze einzuordnen was wir da
gerade gehört haben Andreas Einsatz fand
ich bemerkenswert den der Außenminister
gesagt hat und zwar als er angesprochen
wurde eben auf die Frage auf ein
bisschen Kritik warum die Evakuierung
erst zu spät gestartet ist da hat er
also gesagt das war eine Entscheidung
diese die ja jederzeit auch noch mal
genauso treffen würde also der Zeitpunkt
wann sie eben gestartet haben das alles
vorzubereiten und das war wohl auch in
Abstimmung mit anderen bot so hat er das
immer wieder betont das kam mehrfach wie
ist da deine Analyse ja also er hat auf
diese Frage das würde er genau wieder so
machen das war die Frage danach warum
ist die deutsche Botschaft erst so spät
evakuiert worden da gab es ja sehr
konkrete Berichte über Warnungen des
deutschen Botschafters in Kabul der
schon Ende vergangener Woche wohl gesagt
hat wir müssen die Botschaft evakuieren
nehmt das ernst in Berlin das hier ist
eine sehr sehr heikle Frage und das hat
Maß diese Berichte hat Mars im Prinzip
dementiert und gesagt das war so nicht
und wir haben unsere
Botschaftsangehörigen genauso behandelt
wie das die anderen Länder mit ihren
Botschaftsangehörigen auch getan haben
das würde er jederzeit wieder tun er hat
jetzt eingeräumt zum ersten Mal übrigens
das dann die deutschen
Botschaftsangehörigen mit US- oder
Hubschraubern evakuiert werden mussten
weil eben andere Möglichkeiten schon
versperrt waren was ja ein bisschen
dafür ist dass es wirklich sehr sehr
spät war als die Botschaft evakuiert
wurde aber auch da hat er gesagt dass
seien anderen Botschaften nicht anders
gewesen also maas hat ja gestern gesagt
ganz grundsätzlich man habe die la wir
alle haben die Lage falsch eingeschätzt
und unter wir alle hat er genannt die
internationale Gemeinschaft die
Nachrichtendienste und die
Bundesregierung also das war gestern
sein Schuldeingeständnis und auch ja so
dass weiteste weiter vielleicht gehen
konnte ohne sein Rücktritt gleich
anbieten zu müssen dass heute war eine
Verteidigung glaube ich eher in einer
sehr konkreten Sache bei den konkreten
vorwurfbotschaft
außerdem hat er angesprochen dass es
also jetzt tatsächlich mehrere Flüge
allein heute meine ich gehört zu haben
zwei weitere Flüge geben soll auf denen
auch Menschen die jetzt eben keinen
deutschen Pass haben mitkommen sollen
das ist aber so ein bisschen auch davon
abhängig natürlich wer in den Bereich
des Flughafens kommt was hat er denn
darüber gesagt wie sie das sicherstellen
wollen vor Ort dass das vielleicht auch
besser funktioniert als jetzt zuvor
genau er hat gesagt zwei weitere Flüge
das wären dann insgesamt fünf seit
Beginn der Evakuierungsaktion er hat
gesagt dass es jetzt eine Schleuse gibt
am Flughafen wo sich die Leute die von
den deutschen evakuiert werden sollen
melden sollen und er hat gesagt dass die
Taliban bisher alle Leute mit
ausländischen Pass an ihren Checkpoints
durchlassen und das ist ja genau das
Problem der ist ja Waage geblieben was
mit den Afghanen passieren soll da hat
er gesagt man arbeite an einer Lösung
gemeinsam mit den Partnern vor allen
Dingen mit den USA aber das ist und
bleibt offenbar das Hauptproblem wie
kommen die Afghanen überhaupt zum
Flughafen die Menschen die sich gerade
in irgendwelchen Häusern irgendwo
verstecken die auf der Flucht sind mit
ihren Kindern mit ihrer habe die Angst
haben vor jedem Checkpoint wo die
Taliban sind das ist noch nicht gelöst
das Problem was für mich noch neu war
ist die Lufthansa dass er angekündigt
hat dass die
Lufthansa die Passagiere oder die
Menschen die nach aus über die
Luftbrücke nach Taschkent gerettet
werden dass die Lufthansa dann diese
Passagiere wiederum nach Deutschland
fliegt das ist eine große Erleichterung
die Lufthansa hatte das Angeboten in den
vergangenen Tagen und sie kann natürlich
solche Langstreckenflüge machen ohne zum
Beispiel Zwischenstopp für einen Tank
fürs Tanken einzulegen die A400M müssen
auf diesem Weg tanken also ich fand das
noch ganz bemerkenswert
aber so im großen Ganzen betrachtet aus
der Perspektive der Menschen in
Afghanistan ja es gibt jetzt ein paar
kleine Fortschritte aber das große
Hauptproblem wie kommen die Menschen
durch zum Flughafen das ist nicht gelöst
und da ist offenbar auch noch keine
Lösung in Sicht
damit hast du jetzt auch schon eine
Frage im Stream beantwortet von
thunderstorm der eben gerne wissen
wollte also wer werden auch ortskräfte
durchgelassen und hast damit ja jetzt
auch noch mal die Problematik
angesprochen es gibt eine weitere Frage
und zwar von Blackstar bei Arni
Entschuldigung diese hier von sento bei
Youtube gibt es heute auch eine
Stellungnahme der Kanzlerin und da haben
wir was vorliegen und wollen da auch
jetzt erst noch mal gerne reinhören
deshalb ist es für uns natürlich ganz
wichtig alles zu tun um möglichst viele
Menschen außer Landes zu bringen und sie
wissen ich habe darüber gestern ja auch
berichtet werde heute auch die
Fraktionsvorsitzende noch einmal
unterrichten dass die Bundesregierung
alles tut um hier auch
erfolgreich zu sein oder zumindest das
zu erreichen was unter den schwierigen
Bedingungen möglich ist und da ist es
eine gute Nachricht dass jetzt eine
zweite Maschine nach der Landung heute
Nacht in Kabul eingetroffen ist
Andreas es gab auch eine Frage relativ
am Schluss eines Kollegen da ging es
darum dass also erst hieß es ja es
können auch nur Leute mit die auf
sogenannten Listen stehen und das
scheint jetzt aufgehoben ist das richtig
oder wie ist das einzuschätzen ja das
ist schwierig und das ist auch genau die
Frage die hier Berlin so elektrisiert
ist es so dass auf diese Flugzeuge der
deutschen nur Leute dürfen die auf der
Liste stehen also wenn jetzt
Außenminister Maß sagt wir haben eine
Schleuse ein Tor am Flughafen
eingerichtet wo man sich melden soll ja
wer kommt denn durch das Tor kommt da
jetzt wirklich jeder rein also da würde
ich mal vermuten nein die haben eine
Liste und wer da drauf steht kommt durch
andererseits hat aber tatsächlich heute
die
Verteidigungsministerin gesagt wir
nehmen jeden mit der mit will das ist
für mich ein kleiner Widerspruch
eigentlich ist es sogar ganz großer
Widerspruch und der ist für mich noch
nicht aufgelöst
es gibt noch eine weitere Frage hier bei
uns im Stream von veni wie die Wiki und
zwar werden jetzt alle nach Deutschland
gebracht auch dazu haben wir meine ich
was gehört
ja dazu hat darüber redet ja Berlin
jetzt auch schon seit Tagen da hat Maß
angesprochen den sonderministerrat der
Außenminister der heute stattfindet also
die EU-Außenminister werden sich heute
virtuell treffen dann nimmt jetzt Maß
gleich dran teil das findet jetzt in
diesem Minuten statt und da ist eben
jetzt die Frage was macht man mit den
nicht-deutschen die man rettet dass
Szenario was natürlich der deutschen
Bundesregierung am liebsten wäre ist
dass man sie in den Nachbarländern den
Flüchtlingslager steckt aber
auf diesem eu-sonderministerrat wird es
darum gehen dass man Kontingente
vereinbart in der EU wie viele
Flüchtlinge wie viele nicht deutsche
jedes Land aufnimmt denn eins ist ja
auch klar die afghanischen ortskräfte
die für Deutschland
gearbeitet gedolmetscht gefahren sind
gewaschen haben die kann man ja nicht
einfach in irgendeinen Flüchtlingslager
im Nachbarland stecken sondern denen ist
Deutschland schon deutlich mehr schuldig
aber wir wissen ja alle aus der
flüchtlingskrise von
2014/2015 wie unglaublich schwer es ist
in der EU flüchtlingskontingente zu
vereinbaren dazu kommt noch das in
Deutschland gerade Wahlkampf herrscht
und das Thema extrem und populär ist es
gibt also ja auch schon vom
cdu-kanzlerkandidaten Laschet zum
Beispiel Äußerungen die auch darauf
hindeuten dass sich 2015 nicht
wiederholen soll damit meint er nicht
dass man keine Flüchtlinge mehr aufnimmt
sondern damit meint er dass man eben
zuerst auch in den Nachbarländern helfen
soll dass ich dort die Flüchtlinge gut
ansiedeln sollen aber diese Frage
Flüchtlinge Aufnahme von Kontingenten
wie viele Kontingente wie hoch sollen
die sein das wird eine Frage sein die
noch sehr hitzig debattiert wird und
nicht nur in Deutschland sondern auch in
den anderen EU-Hauptstädten
vielen Dank Andreas kühners für diese
Analyse dieser Einschätzung zur
Pressekonferenz vom Bundesaußenminister
Heiko Maas vielen Dank nach Berlin
es gibt Fragen von euch auch per Mail
insbesondere eben nach der Situation von
den ortskräften mit den afghanischen
Pässen also hier kam eine Frage eben zu
uns rein also wie stellt man jetzt diese
Rettung dieser Menschen sicher die eben
für die Bundeswehr beispielsweise in
Marseille Sharif gearbeitet haben und
die Menschen oder hier Deutschland über
all die Jahre unterstützt haben und wir
haben gesprochen vor dieser Sendung das
haben wir aufzeichnen müssen mit einer
ortskraft einem afghanischen Dolmetscher
vor Ort in Afghanistan der von 2006 bis
2013 eben als Übersetzer gearbeitet hat
für ein bilaterales polizeiprojekt der
deutschen Bundespolizei in Masa isarif
und er sitzt nun fest in Kabul zunächst
in einem Safehouse wir sehen jetzt
gerade auch Bilder die sind schon etwas
älter da konnte man sich in diesen safe
houses noch gut aufhalten dort war er
zunächst mit seiner Familie
untergebracht aber auch da war es dann
nicht mehr sicher also dieses Safehouse
musste er verlassen sein Name steht auf
keiner Liste und er hat große Sorgen wie
mit ihm und seiner Familie weitergeht
und ich habe vor dieser Sendung mit ihm
gesprochen
Osmanen
wir erreichen Sie jetzt in Afghanistan
in Kabul ich bin sehr dankbar mit ihnen
reden zu können erzählen Sie mir etwas
zu ihrer Situation in welcher Lage
befinden sie sich aktuell
[Musik]
dass sie mich mit Deutschland verbinden
um meine Meinung sagen zu können die
aktuelle Situationen Afghanistan vor
allem in Kabul ist sehr kritisch sie ist
sehr schlecht seit bekannt ist das
Flugzeug aus den USA und Deutschland in
Afghanistan in Kabul ankommen hat sich
die Hälfte der Bevölkerung Kabuls um den
Flughafen versammelt
[Musik]
der Airport die ganze Welt weiß was hier
aktuell passiert die aktuelle Situation
ist wirklich nicht gut sprechen
sie selber versucht den Flughafen zu
erreichen haben sie schon versucht in
ein Flugzeug zu kommen
am frühen Morgen bin ich zum Flughafen
gegangen ja aber die Situation um den
Flughafen ist dass die Taliban 100
Metern entfernt von ihm sind
ihre Kräfte sagen dass sie das Sagen
haben
auf der airport on the people in here
and closed
im direkten Umfeld des Flughafens
übernehmen die amerikanischen
Streitkräfte die Verantwortung
es sind viele Leute da und es gibt eine
Regel am Flughafen die es Leuten die
alleine kommen verbietet sich dem
Flughafen auf ein Kilometer zu nähern
die Leute am Flughafen sind dort seit
zwei Tagen und können ihn nicht
verlassen sie schlafen da und bewegen
sich nicht weg
viele Familien sind im Hinterhof die
Familien erhalten dort keine Auskunft
sie warten nur
bin ich bei meiner Familie ich habe
kleine Kinder ich konnte sie nicht
mitbringen weil es sehr riskant ist seit
gestern sind viele Leute gestorben
if you can tell me why you had to leave
kannst Du mir noch mal sagen wieso du
das Land verlassen musst
wir haben ein Telefonanruf bekommen dass
den Taliban bekannt ist dass einige
afghanische ortskräfte die für
Deutschland arbeiten in den Safe houses
auf ihren Flug warten
darum sind die hingegangen um die Lage
zu überprüfen zum Glück hatten wir das
Safehouse schon evakuiert sie waren
schon dabei das erste safehaus zu
durchsuchen ich war verantwortlich für
das dritte safehaus ich hatte das dritte
schnell evakuiert
bist du auf einer Liste um das Land zu
verlassen bist du in Kontakt mit
deutschen Institutionen bist du
gemeinsam mit deiner Familie auf einer
Liste
mit Deutschland zu telefonieren einige
Anrufe wurden angenommen
im Moment wissen wir aber nicht wirklich
ob unsere Namen auf der Liste stehen wir
wurden nicht angerufen und daher warten
wir noch
willst du versuchen noch mal zum
Flughafen zu gehen um auf eine Liste zu
kommen auch ohne deine Kinder du hattest
vorher gesagt dass es nicht sicher ist
für deine Kinder oder glaubst du dass es
einfach zu unsicher ist gerade am
Flughafen
ich war für drei Stunden am Flughafen
ich habe dort mein Bestes versucht ich
konnte aus der Ferne mit Ausländern
reden ich habe sie gefragt was wird mit
uns passieren sie sagten nur die die ein
ausländischen Pass haben dürfen
hierherkommen und die die ein
Telefonanruf bekommen haben aber die die
keinen Anruf oder ein Visum haben dürfen
einfach nicht weiter sie müssen weit
weggehen es gibt keinen Weg sie sagten
dass sie keine andere Wahl hätten als zu
schießen daher bin ich nach drei Stunden
nach Hause zurückgekehrt ich denke
darüber nach ob ich mit meiner Familie
zurückgehen sollte oder nicht aber
einige der Familien warten dort ohne ein
Ergebnis
vielen Dank Osman dass du mit uns
gesprochen hast ich hoffe du kannst es
schaffen in dieser schwierigen Situation
danke schön
wir sprechen nun mit Erik Marquardt
Mitglied des Europaparlaments und
Mitglied des Bündnis 90 die Grünen über
Kritik die er geäußert hat sehr heftig
teilweise auch bei Twitter aber auch
zunächst mal vielleicht über seine
Erfahrungen und das was er gehört hat
aus Afghanistan Herr Marquardt müsste
uns jetzt zugeschaltet sein hallo Herr
Marquardt schön dass sie heute sich Zeit
genommen haben ich habe heute bei
Twitter gelesen dass auch sie gesagt
haben sie haben von Betroffenen also
ähnliche Geschichten gehört wie wir sie
gerade von Osman den wir übrigens aus
Sicherheitsgründen verpixelt haben dass
er einfach sicher bleibt auch in
Afghanistan also sie haben ähnliche
Geschichten gehört ist das richtig von
den Menschen zu denen sie dort Kontakt
haben
das ist korrekt ich bin schon seit
einigen Tagen sowohl in Kontakt mit
deutschen Staatsangehörigen als auch mit
ortskräften und man hört eigentlich
durch die Bank weg dass man nicht nur
weiß ob man ein Flieger bekommt man
kriegt teilweise nicht mal Antworten vom
Auswärtigen Amt auf die E-Mails die man
dorthin schickt also die Leute fühlen
sich allein gelassen wenn einer
ortskraft die sechs Jahre für die
Bundeswehr gearbeitet hat hat mir gesagt
sie weiß nicht weiter wenn man nicht
erschießt sagt doch bitte dass ich seit
Mai versuche hier aus dem Land zu kommen
andere der Weg zum Flughafen scheint
eben für die Menschen mit dem
afghanischen Pass ein Problem zu sein
und da habe ich gelesen sie haben
ähnliche Geschichten gehört können Sie
da noch ein bisschen auch mal schildern
was was das ist was Sie also von ihren
Kontakten gehört haben
genau es gibt auf der einen Seite
Taliban wegsperren viele wissen aber
auch gar nicht sollen sie es versuchen
dort durchzukommen man kann diese
wegsperren wohl bestechen man kommt dann
noch durch aber ich habe auch gehört
dass es nicht nur die Taliban wegsperren
sind sondern dass eben auch
US-Streitkräfte die den Flughafen
absichern momentan nur Leute mit
deutscher Staatsangehörigkeit
durchlassen und die anderen vertreiben
wieder wegschicken das ist wirklich
unwürdig wenn man dann Pressekonferenzen
hört in denen man sagt wir wollen jetzt
auch ortskräfte evakuieren wenn man den
ortskräften dann auch schreibt das haben
einige gesagt Sie haben Nachrichten
bekommen dass sie jetzt zum Flughafen
kommen können und dann stellt sich das
als enter heraus obwohl das Ministerium
das gesagt hat wer weiß die rechte Hand
offenbar nicht was die linke tut und es
ist einfach insgesamt ein viel zu
langsames zu bürokratisches auch zu
spätes Verhalten man hat das Gefühl dass
ich die Bundesregierung wundert dass die
Taliban auch am Wochenende arbeiten
wir sehen jetzt auch gerade live ein
paar Bilder von vor Ort aus Afghanistan
ich möchte aber jetzt mal kurz auch auf
Kommentare eben aus dem Stream eingehen
und zwar also sie haben sich eben in den
letzten Tagen auch immer wieder sehr
kritisch bei Twitter geäußert in
Richtung Bundesregierung und Patrick
64697 möchte bei Youtube wissen wieso
wurde der Antrag der Grünen also ihrer
Partei zur rechtzeitigen Rettung der
ortskräfte von der SPD abgelehnt zu
formuliert ist Patrick können Sie dazu
was sagen
der Antrag wurde ja vor zwei Monaten
abgelehnt wir haben beantragt dass man
unbürokratisch jetzt schnell ortskräfte
evakuiert und das haben nicht nur die
SPD ähm Mitglieder der SPD-Fraktion
abgelehnt sondern auch die CDU und die
CSU also die Regierung hat abgelehnt
dass man ortskräften unbürokratisch
hilft man muss sie aber klar machen das
war vielleicht nicht so öffentlich aber
dass wir eigentlich seit 2015 eine
breite Diskussion haben darüber wie kann
man auskräften besser helfen schon nach
dem Teilabzug der Bundeswehr hat man
versucht von der Bundesregierung aus
möglichst wenige Menschen aufzunehmen
man hat eigentlich eine Strategie
gefahren bei der man erreichen wollte
dass möglichst wenige Menschen in Europa
in Deutschland ankommen und ja diese
moralische bankrotserklärung zahlt sich
jetzt aus
und sie haben sich ja also wie gesagt
immer wieder kritisch geäußert aber man
muss jetzt sagen also insgesamt gesehen
20 Jahre deutsche Außenpolitik wo ja
auch die Grünen mit einem Außenminister
mal beteiligt waren also wieso stehen
wir jetzt so vor dieser Situation vor
diesem Desaster kann man es ja auch
nennen von dem wir jetzt gerade stehen
also was ist da alles schief gelaufen
ist 20 Jahre sind noch lange Zeit da
hätte viel passieren können
ich glaube man muss das ehrlich auch
Arbeiten es ist auch so dass wir
natürlich fraktionsübergreifend im
Bundestag schauen müssen dass wir auch
auf europäischer Ebene schauen müssen
wie konnte es denn so laufen wie es
jetzt gelaufen ist dass man solche
falsche Einschätzung zu der Lage vor Ort
hatte und zwar über Jahre hinweg
offenbar ich glaube dass ein Teil der
Lösung oder der Antwort auf diese Frage
auch ist dass wir wahrscheinlich über
Jahre hinweg Lageberichte für
Afghanistan geschönt haben um
innenpolitisch Druckpunkt zu haben zu
sagen wir können auch Afghanistan
abschieben sogar in das unsicherste Land
der Welt können wir abschieben man
wollte eigentlich Menschen abschrecken
die aus Afghanistan fliehen wollen
Abschiebung durchführen und hat deswegen
wahrscheinlich Lageberichte geschönt das
zahlt sich jetzt aus man hatte also
keine realistische Einschätzung von der
Situation vor Ort
sie sind auch Mitglied des
Europaparlaments heute in der
Pressekonferenz mit dem
Bundesaußenminister haben wir auch
gehört dass natürlich jetzt also vieles
innerhalb der EU abgesprochen werden
muss im eu-kreis das ist zum einen der
Umgang mit den Taliban aber auch eben
die Fluchtbewegungen so hat es der
Bundesaußenminister genannt haben sie
dazu schon irgendwelche näheren
Informationen sie selbst
also ich finde das erstmal völlig
beschämt dass man jetzt schon versucht
Stimmung aufzugreifen und zu sagen 2015
darf sich nicht wiederholen das heißt ja
übersetzt man möchte eben keine
geflüchteten aufnehmen es ist richtig
dass viele Menschen in die angrenzenden
Region fliehen werden und dass sie dort
humanitäre Hilfe brauchen es ist aber
auch richtig dass man jetzt über die
Aufnahme von Schutzsuchenden reden muss
das ist aber eine Diskussion für die
nächsten Tage für die nächsten Stunden
würde ich mir wünschen dass endlich eine
Ansage gemacht wird wer kann sich denn
jetzt noch auf die Bundesregierung
verlassen es gibt ja immer noch viele
ortskräfte die nach Definition der
Bundesregierung gar keine ortskräfte
sind die nicht wissen ob sie irgendwann
bedacht sind oder nicht und es gibt zum
Beispiel ganz praktische Probleme wie
sollen denn Menschen durch Taliban
wegsperren kommen wenn sie ihre ganzen
Dokumente mitnehmen müssen um dann an
den US Checkpoints durchzukommen also
man kann ja nicht mit einem deutschen
Arbeitsvertrag bei den Taliban
vorbeischauen man muss also organisieren
dass auch digitale Möglichkeiten ganz
schnell unbürokratisch geschaffen werden
auf die Gefahr hin dass man dann
vielleicht auch zwei drei Leute mitnimmt
die vielleicht noch nicht jetzt einen
Antrag zu Ende ausgefüllt haben es ist
jetzt auch nicht die Zeit für Formulare
und Listen sondern eigentlich die Zeit
dafür einen Personenkreis aus einigen
hundert vielleicht 1000 Leuten erstmal
sicher in den Flughafen zu bekommen und
diesen Menschen dann eben auch die
Möglichkeit zu geben dass sie im
Zweifelsfalle die Flieger die ja fliegen
dann auffüllen können das ist mir alles
so viel zu bürokratisch diese Dienst
nach Vorschriften dass sich Ministerien
gegenseitig die Verantwortung zu
schieben statt das endlich jemand
Entscheidung trifft dass ja ich finde
nicht die richtigen Worte aber es ist
störend
es gibt viele offene Fragen vieles was
da noch geklärt werden muss vieles von
dem werden wir auch heute natürlich
nicht mehr schaffen deswegen für den
Moment würde ich mich bedanken sowohl
bei Ihnen als aber auch bei natürlich
allen die jetzt hier im Stream
zugeschaut und Fragen gestellt haben und
wir bleiben natürlich weiter an dem
Thema dran weil wie gesagt es gibt noch
viele offene Fragen und vor allem für
die Menschen vor Ort natürlich noch sehr
sehr viel Ungewissheit und Unklarheit
wie es überhaupt weitergehen soll aber
bis hierhin zunächst mal vielen Dank und
bis bald